hi I'm Russell Leeds I'm Alistair
Cunningham and welcome to property
investors pod car so out of all of these
which one would you say is the most
passive which one do you see is the
least passive I would say if I'd put
them in order
yeah passiveness yeah passiveness yes
it's a new word created by me you see
the dictionary credit Russell Leeds came
up with passiveness I would say
commercial is probably and the best the
most passive this nurse come here I
would go commercial then if you get
right business yeah I mean to be honest
bite they all can be very passive
because if you you know if you just said
to the let agent just saw it yeah you
know it can they can all be very fast so
in feeling like my hate year malls for
instance I have nothing to do with I
would say essay was the least yeah I
think essay is the least cuz it's most
hands-on and they're still gonna want to
come to you with questions yeah and
stuff like that I say essay was the
least I would say the rest of it you
could get pretty damn passive mmm
with all of that which is great so
basically they do is have a combination
of everything I say even with passive
income though there's always you always
want to kind of oversee it don't ya so
if you've got a business you still want
to you saw me looking at the monthly
figures yeah I met and you still knew
making decisions and you still want to
be whereas if commercial once you've
bought it to it is though you're not
responsible for any of them in turn into
any of their anything you're not
responsible so I would say that was
probably the only one for me
the only issue you'd have a commercial
as if 10 stops paying your rent you'd
need to know about it mmm-hmm but if you
said to the agent 10 starts paying the
rent chase them up but come and get a
new person and technically you could be
you know how many of these could you be
in a coma for 10 years and they would
just carry on good point actually
probably only commercial well again it
depends how passive is depends how much
systemize you've got up so you've got
your broke you've got your eye area
you've got your a bra car you've been a
sort of a variable abreu approved for a
mortgage what verbally abused very
abused verbally approved from August
mortgage brokers is he use it well
Scottish one some of them some of them
are quite quite ruthless but anyway then
what so you've got your brother you've
got your just looking at how thick your
fingers are the massive big uns and so
you've got just distracted just totally
distracted me I just wasn't listening I
was just looking at him thinking his
fingers are literally the size of mine
their bare hands their bare hands these
are all of course they are you got no
gloves on I have to put up with this
every day and every week guys you
haven't for 40 minutes a week probably
entrepreneur if you give the definition
of property investor I'll do project yep
why they're different and when when it
suits to be which one I would say you
were both yeah but probably more
property entrepreneur yeah I would say
that as well so I've probably investor
it's something who is investing in
property for couple appreciation and for
income from that property ie you're
buying a property rented out getting the
money from it mmm-hmm I think that sums
up investor quite well yeah and a
property entrepreneur is someone that
makes money from from property but
without but Ronnie more like a business
so for example if they do rent a
serviced accommodation they're not a new
investor cuz they don't own the
environment they're renting it so
they're acquiring it as a products
they'll be in the middle man became
renting it out again to their being an
entrepreneur a deal sorcerer with the
exact same thing they're making money
from property as an entrepreneur not as
an investor all this week showed the
five top tips to becoming a promise top
tips to proving a deceit about I stutter
all right I don't like this sentence so
looking at how to set up a buy-to-let
property business and someone that's
wanting to get started in property what
steps they need to we mentees a few
times but it's important that you treat
property investing as a business
hundreds it's not a hobby it's a
business and if you've got the business
mindset and you and you see it as as a
business it you can know what I've said
this many times if you treat anything
like a hobby you'll get hobby results
whereas if
treat it like a business you get
business results I think if you're gonna
do it you gotta take it seriously and
you got to setup correctly from the
beginning there's no point in doing it
half-hearted because you will only get
half-hearted results so tell you where
they Blackpool
I know people keep criticizing them at
Blackpool there's so much to be so easy
easy as criticising yeah it's fun but
there's a lot of development planned in
Blackpool
there's Lords and as they clap their
hotels gonna I know a crap hole I know
it's a [ __ ] all but um it is forget
forget that I can't forget it I've been
there become best friends with agents
and right move yep can't see much more
than that just to meet great move your
best friends right move your best friend
it's yeah it's one all that it's quite
sad yeah it's quite sad nice quick what
am I
obviously instead of looking at rubbish
on the internet look at right move if
you're looking to get in probably
embarrassing you should be looking at
houses constantly in the game should be
in the game keep yourself in the game so
once you've found your patch and you've
got your area you should be just keeping
in touch with the agents don't be that
person that never calls them and then
suddenly pop up and you're mourning why
they're not bringing any deals just go
in now if you're in if you happen to be
in the area just go ahead and say hi
have you got any deals this week or what
have you got have you got anything
available the more they see you the more
they know you the more likely they're
going to come to you and say hey Russell
I've got this fantastic deal or don't
it's not on the market yeah you
interested because they know that you're
serious yeah I'm also right movie
there's a lot of hidden gems on
Rightmove understand how it works
Pedro is asked this hey guys hey Pedro
do you need any safety measures for a
four-bed for Tennant HMO or are they
optional eg fire doors smoke alarms fire
extinguishers etc for this for this type
of HR at the moment well you've got ask
yourself and Pedro
yeah oh you guys said Pedro if there's a
fire in your property and somebody dies
how are you gonna feel about that I'm
gonna have a pause for dramatic effect
how are you gonna feel about that buddy
and graphs we have some flames also on
the screen Nick when he says it try say
again we'll get some read
dramatic okay you are a duck so Pedro
let me ask someone if you have a fire at
your property how are you gonna feel if
one of your tenants dies because you
didn't - a fire dog just pause so what
are the steps then let's break it down
right step 1 so in step 1 set some time
aside yeah say that was a crappy little
sign on the script yeah yeah learn how
it'll sit 1 get educated go to crash
course it's free you don't have to pay
anything it's free your time and that's
it ok say it's a flash course crash
course it'll - Luke a defined period of
time to get out there and start meeting
people yeah
step 3 turn off all your social media
for fun
forget fun for this week you're there to
work ok so no TV no socializing just fun
and only socialize if it's for a
business just fun no no no fun
only socialize only socialize if it's
just for business
ok just that we just that week just this
is what I'm working with this guy
commits fun no you can have fun but
commit for that one week you'll not
regret it
you know from its controlled fun
controlled find yeah yeah yeah right
step 4 yeah get out there every single
day and get out there in your area be
warm in the streets you say gum tree and
gum tree open rent spare room all these
places
Rochus brokers any mortgage brokers that
do creative finance in the area smaller
estate agents yeah there's no point but
I personally wouldn't phone them now go
in because I'll tell you why because
they get phone calls day in day out from
people that are looking for deals
make the effort dress smartly go in and
actually see if you can sit down with
them for 5 minutes 10 minutes but just
you and you know just tell what you're
wearing
yeah as you went dress smartly alright
so just get in there and actually sit in
front of people your people relate to
people and if you phone them up you'll
just turn our Paris on the end of a
phone get in there and get me in people
walk the streets go and see houses get
inside property and if even if it's a
Publix on Rightmove I secured a lease
option from a property that was
advertised for sale on Rightmove so
don't tell me it can
be done - done it just looking to sell
my house I want to move on my wife
cheated on me so I'm just like found
that she was sleeping with my neighbor
so I just you know not really by the way
if you're watching this to say I'm not
your neighbour Nick
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]